Larry Keeley is one of those guys with a job that, the more he tries to you explain to you what it is that he does for a living, the more you think, people pay you for that? He consults with companies about innovation, about how to organize themselves to be more competitive, more inventive, foster new ideas, that kind of thing.
拉里·基利（Larry Keeley）就是那种人，他的工作越是努力向你解释，你就越觉得：居然真有人会为这个付钱？他为企业提供创新咨询，指导他们如何重组以提高竞争力、提升创造力、孕育新想法等等。
So February of last year, he's giving a talk about all this to some executives who have gathered at a fancy golf course in Florida. And after the talk, two military men in the audience ask him to lunch. As they're being served, one of them asked what he knew about the 1993 bombing of the World Trade Center building.
去年二月，他在佛罗里达州的一个高档高尔夫球场向一群聚集在那里的高管发表了关于这一切的演讲。演讲结束后，听众中的两名军人邀请他共进午餐。在用餐时，其中一人问他对1993年世贸中心爆炸案了解多少。
So he's asking me if I knew any of the details. And I said, no. And he started to tell me the gory details about the analysis of that bombing. And of course, what they use are people who go in afterwards and do forensic analysis of a calamity.
他问我是否了解任何细节，我说不知道。于是他开始向我讲述那次爆炸案分析中的血腥细节。当然，他们采用的方法是让专家在事后进入现场，对灾难进行法医分析。
And what was fascinating about the forensic analysis is that the forensic teams didn't quite agree. Some said the bombs were placed 12 centimeters away from where they would have needed to be to destroy the major support column in the North Tower. Others said, no, no, no, you got it all wrong. The bombs were four centimeters away from where they needed to be to destroy that column.
法医分析最令人着迷的是，法医团队的意见并不完全一致。有人说，炸弹的安放位置与摧毁北塔主要支撑柱所需的最佳位置偏离了12厘米。另一些人则反驳说，不，你们全搞错了，炸弹距离所需位置只有4厘米。
By the way, pretty alarming.
顺便说一句，这相当令人担忧。
And it turns out that one of the guys I'm lunching with is a major general, George Close, a brilliant guy. And he turns out to be hand-picked by the Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff to think through something called the revolution in military affairs.
事实证明，和我共进午餐的人之一是乔治·克洛斯（George Close）少将，一个非常出色的人。原来他是由参谋长联席会议主席亲自挑选，负责深入思考所谓的“军事事务革命”。
When I got a little bit of explanation about this revolution in military affairs, they said, we're in the middle of one. And I said, OK. And they said, they don't happen very often, we think there's been maybe 12 of them in history. What that means is that everything that is normal and the way we engage, fight a conflict, and win it will go through a change.
当我稍微了解了一些关于军事事务革命的情况后，他们说，我们正处于这样一场革命中。我说，哦。他们接着说，这种情况在历史上并不常见，我们认为历史上可能也就发生过12次。这意味着我们习以为常的一切，包括我们参与、进行冲突以及获胜的方式，都将经历一场变革。
So one of the early historic examples was the invention of gunpowder. And you think about the world of gladiator, and you see the kind of conflict that gun powder transformed forever. People that are rushing up to the enemy with their horses, wearing 300 pounds of armor and rushing up to the enemy and whacking him with something sharp. That was the nature of battle in those days.
火药的发明就是早期历史中的一个例子。想想角斗士的世界，看看火药永远改变的那种冲突形式。人们骑着马冲向敌人，穿着300磅重的铠甲，冲向对方并用尖锐的东西砍杀。这就是当时战争的本质。
Well gun powder comes along, cannons get cheap, they put them on wheels, they can haul them to the enemy's fortress. That's a revolution in military affairs.
后来火药出现了，大炮变得便宜了，人们把它装上轮子，就能拉到敌人的堡垒前。这就是一场军事事务革命。
And I'm sitting there listening to this and they've happened so seldom in the history of the world. Every time a revolution in military affairs has occurred in history, the party in power at the beginning has not been in power at the end. And they got a lot of historians at the Pentagon. And those historians had convinced the senior generals that we were in the midst of a revolution in military affairs with these basic principles.
我坐在那儿听着，这种革命在世界历史上发生的次数太少了。历史上每一次军事事务革命发生时，掌权的势力在革命开始时往往不会在结束时依然掌权。五角大楼有许多历史学家，正是这些历史学家让高级将领们确信，我们正处于这样一场以基本原则为基础的军事事务革命之中。
Which brings us to the first World Trade Center bombing in 1993. These particular generals were convinced that it was an example of this new kind of warfare. The way the thing was organized, through a web of operatives, the low-tech way it was carried out, the fact that it was on American soil and targeted at something so symbolic as the World Trade Center towers.
这就把我们带回了1993年的世贸中心爆炸案。这些将军们确信，这就是这种新型战争的一个例子。它的组织方式是通过一个行动者网络，实施手段采用低技术方式，而且它发生在美利坚合众国的土地上，目标还是像世贸大厦这样具有象征意义的建筑。
February of last year, these Pentagon officials were trying to think about how they should fight back. And they wanted to learn to think differently. They wanted to learn to think like their enemy. So they called on a bunch of guys in the private sector, like Keeley, for advice on how to think differently, how to change.
去年二月，这些五角大楼的官员正在思考他们该如何反击。他们想学会换个角度思考，想学会像敌人一样思考。因此，他们邀请了基利这类私营部门的人士，寻求关于如何改变思维方式的建议。
US military strategy right now is based on the idea that we will win wars through overwhelming force. That's the idea, overwhelming force. We will throw all the bombs, and planes, and missiles at the enemy, the best technology that money can buy, and a lot of it, just simply overwhelm them in a full-out attack.
美国目前的军事战略基于这样一个理念：我们要通过压倒性的武力赢得战争。这就是那个理念：压倒性武力。我们要向敌人倾泻所有的炸弹、飞机和导弹，动用金钱能买到的最好的技术，而且要大量使用，通过一场全面进攻彻底压倒他们。
And Keeley says that it was not clear if the Pentagon could change to something so low-tech and sneaky.
基利说，不清楚五角大楼是否能够转型去应对这种低技术、隐蔽式的威胁。
One of the things we have is money, material in spades. To challenge elite forces to be able to overcome a vastly superior enemy, with next to nothing. That is just completely the opposite of the way we think. And it's logical that we wouldn't think that way. Because we start with the presumption that we're the mightiest, and the biggest, with the greatest technologies.
我们拥有的资源是金钱和装备。要挑战精英部队，让他们能够以近乎一无所有的状态克服强大的敌人，这与我们的思维方式截然相反。我们不那样想是很合乎逻辑的，因为我们首先假设自己是最强大、最庞大、拥有最先进技术的国家。
Right. You're saying that in order to fight these kind of sort of guerrilla terrorist actions, they have to become guerrilla terrorists.
没错，你是说为了对抗这种游击式恐怖行动，他们必须变成游击恐怖分子。
I don't know if they have to become them, but they have to be able to think like them.
我不知道他们是否非得变成那样，但他们必须能够像他们一样思考。
Keeley says that the military brass that he talked to wanted to be able to do that, but also knew quite well how difficult that would be. It is hard to imagine the world from someone else's point of view.
基利说，他交谈过的军方高层想要具备这种能力，但也非常清楚这有多难。从别人的角度来看待世界是很困难的。
Today on our radio program, we try to do that. We bring you three stories, a kind of current events Rashomon. Each of the stories on our show today is something that you've heard of in the news, and we invite people with a different perspective, hopefully, than the one you already know.
今天，我们在广播节目中尝试这样做。我们带来了三个故事，一种“当前事件版”的《罗生门》。节目中的每个故事都是你新闻中听闻过的，我们邀请了与你已知观点可能不同的人来讲述，希望通过不同的视角带来新的理解。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，播出的是《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today in three acts: Act One, 1001 Arabian nightly newscasts. A Palestinian teenager from Chicago in that story explains why everything that you think you know about the World Trade Center and Pentagon attacks is absolutely wrong.
我们今天的节目分为三幕：第一幕，《1001个阿拉伯夜晚新闻》。故事中，一位来自芝加哥的巴勒斯坦裔青少年解释了为什么你认为自己了解的关于世贸中心和五角大楼袭击的一切都是绝对错误的。
Act Two, bombs over Baghdad. We hear the story of the Persian Gulf War, told by a family man from Baghdad who was drafted into Saddam's army against his will. Who had to explain to his 3-year-old son why those nice Americans were bombing their city, night after night.
第二幕，《巴格达上空的炸弹》。我们听到了海湾战争的故事，由一位来自巴格达的顾家男人讲述，他在违背意愿的情况下被征召入萨达姆的军队，不得不向他3岁的儿子解释，为什么那些“好心的”美国人每天晚上都在轰炸他们的城市。
Act Three, Toto, I don't think we're in Vietnam anymore. US special operations forces will lead the first part of the coming war that we are all bracing for. We hear how a simple half hour mission turned into a bloody all-day battle one of the last times they went out, just a few years ago.
第三幕，《托托，我想我们不在越南了》。美国特种作战部队将领导我们都在准备迎接的未来战争的第一阶段。我们听到了仅仅几年前，他们最后一次出任务时，一个简单的半小时任务是如何演变成一场血腥的全天战斗的。
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
Act One. 1001 Arabian nightly newscasts.
第一幕，《1001个阿拉伯夜晚新闻》。
You know, asking what Arab Americans or Muslims think about recent news is as ridiculous as asking what Christians think. There is no one answer to that question, it is such a diverse community.
你知道，询问阿拉伯裔美国人或穆斯林对最近新闻的看法，就像询问基督徒有什么看法一样荒谬。这个问题没有统一答案，因为这是一个如此多元的群体。
For this next story, we wanted to hear from somebody whose views do not necessarily agree with what most Americans believe. We did this specifically so that we could better understand why they believe what it is that they believe.
对于下一个故事，我们想听听那些观点未必符合大多数美国人信仰的人的声音。我们这样做正是为了更好地理解他们为什么会持有那样的信仰。
Our senior producer Julie Snyder visited with an 18-year-old Palestinian American named Rawah starting the week of the attacks on the World Trade Center and the Pentagon. Rawah is a freshman in college. She's studying computers, living at home with her parents. She wears more traditional clothes at home, but jeans and a sweatshirt at school. She's religious enough that she always keeps her head covered in public. Here's Julie's report.
我们的资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）在世贸中心和五角大楼遇袭那周，采访了一位18岁的巴勒斯坦裔美国女孩拉瓦（Rawah）。拉瓦是一名大学新生，学习计算机，与父母住在一起。她在家里穿得比较传统，但在学校穿牛仔裤和运动衫。她很有宗教信仰，在公共场合总是戴着头巾。这是朱莉的报道。
Whenever I visit Rawah's family's apartment, the TV is always on. They only watch the Arabic satellite channels, there are 10 or 15 of them from Jordan, Iraq, Lebanon, Saudi Arabia, the Emirates. There are movies, soap operas, there's even an Egyptian version of Who Wants to be a Millionaire that is almost exactly the same as ours-- but in their version, instead of cash prices, you win bars of gold.
每当我造访拉瓦家时，电视总是开着的。他们只看阿拉伯语卫星频道，有10到15个台，分别来自约旦、伊拉克、黎巴嫩、沙特阿拉伯和阿联酋。有电影、肥皂剧，甚至还有埃及版的《谁想成为百万富翁》，内容几乎和我们的一模一样——但在他们的版本里，奖品不是现金，而是金条。
There, as here, some newscasts are more reliable than others. Al Jazeera is sort of like CNN. Abu Dhabi is closer to Fox News.
和这里一样，有些新闻报道比其他的更可靠。半岛电视台（Al Jazeera）有点像CNN，阿布扎比电视台则更接近福克斯新闻。
Three days after the attacks, it's Rawah, her mother, brother, sister, brother-in-law, and me, sitting on the couch watching Abu Dhabi. The scene on the TV is like watching the news in a parallel universe. It's a reporter doing a stand up in front of the charred and collapsed portion of the Pentagon, just like any other reporter. Except he's speaking in Arabic, talking emotionally, and gesturing emphatically, saying the US doesn't have proof linking the attacks to Arabs and there seems to be almost no proof linking the attacks to Osama bin Laden, but that everyone in the United States is jumping to conclusions.
袭击发生三天后，拉瓦、她的母亲、兄弟、姐妹、姐夫和我坐在沙发上看着阿布扎比电视台。电视上的场景就像在平行宇宙看新闻。那是一位记者在五角大楼烧焦和坍塌的部分前进行现场报道，就像其他任何记者一样。不同的是他用阿拉伯语说话，情绪激动，手势夸张，说美国没有证据证明袭击与阿拉伯人有关，似乎几乎没有任何证据将袭击与奥萨马·本·拉登联系起来，但美国每个人都在仓促下结论。
On hearing the news, Rawah's family nods in agreement. Her brother-in-law turns to remind me of the Oklahoma City bombing, where immediate reports pinned the blame on Arabs. The Arabic channels have been talking about this, and about Timothy McVeigh's recent execution, and how these attacks might be related to that.
听到这消息，拉瓦的家人点头表示赞同。她姐夫转向我，提醒我俄克拉何马城爆炸案的情况，当时最初的报道也将矛头指向阿拉伯人。阿拉伯频道一直在讨论这件事，以及蒂莫西·麦克维（Timothy McVeigh）最近的处决，并讨论这些袭击是否可能与之有关。
He talks about various American militia groups I've never heard of that want revenge for McVeigh's execution
他谈到了各种我从未听说过的美国民兵组织，他们想为麦克维的死报仇。
I tell him, I honestly don't know much about that.
我告诉他，我确实对这些了解不多。
He tells me it's reported all the time on the satellite TV.
他告诉我，卫星电视上一直在报道。
This is the 12 o'clock news.
这是12点的新闻。
This is Rawah.
这是拉瓦。
This report is saying that Israel is taking advantage of all the media turning to America and reporting what's happening. And they are bombing more homes and killing more Palestinians in Palestine.
这篇报道说，以色列正在利用媒体将焦点转向美国并报道正在发生的事情。他们正在巴勒斯坦轰炸更多的家园，杀害更多的巴勒斯坦人。
In fact, in the first few days after the attack on the World Trade Center, Israel did step up military actions in the occupied territories. In the West Bank town of Ramallah, where Rawah's sister lives, Israelis launched missiles from helicopters and leveled a building used by a Palestinian intelligence agency, killing one person and injuring 120 others. Rawah's sister called to say that she and her son had been sleeping in their laundry room because it's the only room without windows.
事实上，在世贸中心遇袭后的最初几天，以色列确实在被占领土加强了军事行动。在拉瓦的姐姐居住的西岸城镇拉马拉，以色列军队从直升机上发射导弹，夷平了一座巴勒斯坦情报机构使用的建筑物，造成一人死亡，120人受伤。拉瓦的姐姐打来电话说，她和儿子一直睡在洗衣房里，因为那是唯一没有窗户的房间。
Naturally, this was big news on Arabic TV. And while it was reported by Western news agencies like UPI and Reuters, because of the Trade Center and Pentagon attacks, it was hardly mentioned in American newscasts and newspapers.
自然，这在阿拉伯电视台上是大新闻。虽然美联社（UPI）和路透社等西方通讯社也有报道，但由于世贸中心和五角大楼遇袭，美国的新闻节目和报纸几乎没有提及。
Rawah and her family say this is typical. Americans who pay close attention to the news hear about Israeli actions against Palestinians. But most of us don't really know these things are happening, and don't get a sense of how severe they are. And this just makes Rawah mad.
拉瓦和她的家人说这是典型的例子。密切关注新闻的美国人会听到以色列针对巴勒斯坦人的行动，但我们大多数人并不真正知道这些事情正在发生，也没有感受到这些行动有多严重。这让拉瓦很生气。
The only channel I don't see these things on is the American channels. I have the Syrian, the Lebanese, the Dubai channels, the Kuwait, the Saudi Arabia, the Iraq. So if all of these channels are bringing it, I'm sure it's not a lie. It's been confirmed on many channels.
唯一看不到这些内容的频道就是美国频道。我有叙利亚、黎巴嫩、迪拜、科威特、沙特阿拉伯、伊拉克的频道。所以如果所有这些频道都在报道，我肯定这不是谎言，很多频道都已经证实了。
When I first Rawah, she spent over an hour showing me around her house and explaining to me her views on the Israelis and their occupation of Palestine. We looked at articles she had written for the local Muslim newspaper. She played me a video she put together off the satellite TV, showing children brutally killed by Israeli shells, and Israeli soldiers shooting farmers at point blank range.
我第一次见到拉瓦时，她花了整整一个小时带我参观她的房子，并向我解释她对以色列人及其占领巴勒斯坦的看法。我们看了她为当地穆斯林报纸写的文章。她给我播放了一个她从卫星电视上剪辑的视频，展示了被以色列炮火残酷杀害的儿童，以及以色列士兵在近距离射杀农民的画面。
The footage was really graphic, filled with blood and body parts. You'd never see footage like it on American TV. Rawah's presentation even went multimedia.
镜头非常震撼，满是鲜血和残肢。你在美国电视上永远看不到这样的画面。拉瓦的展示甚至还用了多媒体。
This is a Powerpoint slideshow. I have gotten the email, first in September, where the Israelis would start attacking the Palestinians. This is a picture of a boy in a hospital. This is a boy who was shot in the head.
这是一个PowerPoint演示幻灯片。我是在9月份第一次收到这封邮件的，当时以色列开始攻击巴勒斯坦人。这是一张在医院的男孩照片。这是一个头部中弹的男孩。
The reason these stories don't appear in the American media, Rawah says, is because certain ethnicities in the media-- and that's the phrase she used, certain ethnicities-- don't want these stories to get out. Her family said the same thing to me. The man at the mosque around the corner from her house said it, too. After I'd spent a few hours with Rawah's family, the phrase "certain ethnicities" just shortened into "Jews."
拉瓦说，这些报道之所以没有出现在美国媒体上，是因为媒体中某些族群——这是她用的词，某些族群——不希望这些报道传出去。她的家人也对我说了同样的话。她家拐角处清真寺的男人也这么说。在我与拉瓦的家人共处几个小时后，“某些族群”这个短语就简化成了“犹太人”。
The fact that they'd say this to a member of the supposed Zionist media conspiracy just shows how hard it is for them to imagine any other explanation for the way Arabs are portrayed in the news. I think it didn't even occur to them that it might be offensive.
事实是，他们居然会对所谓的犹太媒体阴谋论成员说出这种话，这恰恰表明了他们有多么难以想象阿拉伯人在新闻中被刻画的任何其他解释。我想他们甚至没觉得这有什么冒犯之处。
And if all this seems bigotted and hard to swallow, consider how it looks from their side. Rawah hears about all sorts news from her sister, from Arabic TV, that is either downplayed or ignored in the Western media. What else could explain it?
如果这一切看起来既偏执又难以接受，试着从他们的角度想想。拉瓦从她姐姐和阿拉伯电视台上听到的各种新闻，在西方媒体中要么被淡化，要么被忽视。还能有什么解释呢？
Ali Abunimah runs a website where he tracks anti-Arab bias in the American media. He doesn't think there's a Jewish conspiracy skewing the coverage, but he says people believe it because, in their day-to-day experience, Israel seems capable of pulling anything off. Sure, Israelis see themselves as the underdogs, a tiny state surrounded by hostile neighbors. But from a Palestinian perspective, nothing seems beyond Israel's reach.
阿里·阿布尼玛（Ali Abunimah）经营着一个网站，专门跟踪美国媒体中的反阿拉伯偏见。他不认为存在一个犹太阴谋来操纵舆论，但他表示人们会相信，是因为在他们的日常经历中，以色列似乎什么事都做得出来。当然，以色列人将自己视为弱势群体，一个被敌对邻国包围的微小国家。但从巴勒斯坦人的视角来看，没有什么事情是超出以色列能力范围的。
I think there's an issue of power here. When you have an overwhelmingly powerful force like Israel and people who have lived under occupation-- people whose entire life is controlled by the whim of this power, whether you can get up in the morning, go to work, is up to the mood of the Israeli soldier at the checkpoint. Whether your house will be demolished is up to the Israelis. Whether you're allowed in or out of the country is up to the Israelis. Whether you're allowed to go from this village to that village is up to the Israelis. Everything is up to the Israelis.
我认为这里有一个权力问题。当你面对像以色列这样拥有压倒性力量的政权，而人们生活在占领之下——人们的整个生活都由这种权力的心血来潮所控制，早上能否起床、能否去工作，全看检查站以色列士兵的心情。房子是否会被拆毁全看以色列人。是否被允许出入境全看以色列人。是否被允许从这个村庄去那个村庄也全看以色列人。一切都由以色列人决定。
So people experience the Israelis as a powerful, overwhelmingly powerful, force. And in fact, the Israelis have always tried to inculcate that in people, the myth of invincibility, the Israeli secret service, the Mossad, that it has this omnipotence. Which a lot of people believe, especially when they're in a much weaker position. You know, you might believe a lot of things.
所以人们体验到以色列人是一股强大、压倒性的力量。事实上，以色列人一直试图向人们灌输这一点，灌输那种无敌的神话，以色列特勤局摩萨德的无所不能。许多人相信这一点，特别是在他们处于更弱势的情况下。你知道，你可能会相信很多事情。
And look at what Israel has already convinced people of, Ali says. Most of the West believes the creation of the state of Israel was completely fair and just. An inspiring story, refugees from World War II and the Holocaust who finally got a state.
阿里说，看看以色列已经让人们相信了什么。大多数西方人认为以色列国的建立是完全公平正义的。一个鼓舞人心的故事，二战和大屠杀的难民终于拥有了一个国家。
From an Arab perspective, it's incredible.
从阿拉伯人的视角看，这简直不可思议。
It's so different from the experience of Palestinians, who are often brutally and forcibly expelled. And people say, look how Israel got away with doing this to us and getting the world to believe something different. And if they can do that in that most fundamental instance, then what can't they do?
这与巴勒斯坦人的经历截然不同，他们往往是被残酷和强制驱逐的。人们说，看看以色列怎么能做这种事而让全世界相信另一套说辞。如果他们能在如此根本的事件上做到这一点，那还有什么是他们做不到的？
Ali is Palestinian and believes that the biases of the Western press aren't necessarily the things the reporters are even conscious of.
阿里是巴勒斯坦人，他认为西方媒体的偏见甚至未必是记者们自觉意识到的。
Consider the fact that no foreign journalists covering Israel, Palestine, live in the occupied territories. I think there's one, I think the Economist's correspondent lives in Gaza, or at least used to.
考虑到没有外国记者报道以色列和巴勒斯坦时是住在被占领土上的。我想只有一个，经济学人的通讯员住在加沙，或者至少以前住在那儿。
So what happens, is that when a reporter goes there, they become, functionally speaking, an Israeli. You know, they live amongst Israelis. The children go to Israeli schools. They wake up in the morning, they go and get their cup of coffee, they're surrounded by Israelis. And so their fears become those of Israelis.
所以发生的情况是，当记者去那里时，他们从功能上讲就成了以色列人。你知道，他们住在以色列人中间。孩子上以色列学校。他们早上醒来，去喝咖啡，被以色列人包围。因此，他们的恐惧就变成了以色列人的恐惧。
I remember an NPR reporter being interviewed about how she copes with the fear of suicide bombings.
我记得一位美国国家公共电台（NPR）的记者在接受采访时，谈到她如何应对自杀式爆炸的恐惧。
And she said, well I and my friends, you know, we go out a bit less. She was speaking in the first person. So there's no reporter who can speak in the first person as to what it's like to be a Palestinian.
她说，我和我的朋友们，我们出去得少一点。她是用第一人称说的。所以没有记者能用第一人称讲述作为巴勒斯坦人是什么感觉。
So there's an issue of perspective. It's not that there's conscious bias. But if you're living in one place that's totally different, that's like a first world environment, as West Jerusalem is, you're going to have a very different perspective.
所以存在视角问题。这不是因为有自觉的偏见。但如果你生活在一个完全不同的地方，一个像西耶路撒冷那样属于第一世界的环境，你就会有非常不同的视角。
A few days after the September 11th attacks, I gave Rawah a tape recorder to keep a kind of audio diary of her life. About a week into it, she recorded this.
9月11日袭击发生几天后，我给了拉瓦一台录音机，让她记录生活中的音频日记。大约一周后，她录下了这段话。
OK. Right now it's 8:05. And as soon as I got home, my mom told me that on the Arabic satellite they brought that about 4,000 Israeli people that are employed in the World Trade Center did not go to work on Tuesday. And Ariel Sharon was supposed to be in a meeting in New York on Tuesday, but he canceled it.
好的。现在是8点05分。我刚到家，妈妈就告诉我，在阿拉伯卫星电视上报道说，在世贸中心工作的4000名以色列人周二没有去上班。阿里埃勒·沙龙（Ariel Sharon）原本周二要在纽约参加会议，但取消了。
Also, there were Jews, photographers, on top of the building, a few buildings. They were getting ready to take pictures. So the assumption now is that the Jews are the ones who did it.
还有，有一些犹太摄影师在建筑物楼顶，几栋楼上。他们准备拍照。所以现在的假设是犹太人是幕后黑手。
A couple days after Rawah recorded that, I was invited to her house for a lunch being held for her sister-in-law's sister who was visiting from Jordan. Lots of people, huge trays of food were laid out on the coffee tables in front of us, and toddlers and kids swarmed around.
拉瓦录下那段话几天后，我被邀请去她家参加午餐，是为她姐夫的姐妹举办的，她从约旦来访。很多人，巨大的食物托盘摆在我们面前的茶几上，幼儿和孩子们跑来跑去。
At the very end, as we were clearing the dishes, one woman asked me, how come the government and the media are always blaming the Arabs for everything, when they have hardly any evidence? Have you heard about the 4,000 Israelis who didn't show up for work at the World Trade Center on Tuesday?
最后，当我们收拾餐具时，一位女士问我，为什么政府和媒体总是把一切都归咎于阿拉伯人，明明几乎没有证据？你听说过周二那天世贸中心有4000名以色列人没去上班的事吗？
And then again, later, after all the women had gone, Rawah's brother-in-law came over. He runs an Islamic community group and wanted to give me some press releases that have been faxed to him.
后来，女人们都走了，拉瓦的姐夫过来了。他经营着一个伊斯兰社区团体，想给我一些传真过来的新闻稿。
He then told me that it probably didn't matter, and that I wouldn't report it, anyway. But had I heard about the 4,000 Israelis in the World Trade Center?
他接着告诉我，这可能没关系，反正我也不会报道。但你听说过世贸中心那4000名以色列人的事吗？
It's not clear how widely believed this rumor is. It appears to have originated on the Hamas website-- yes, they have a website. And then was spread on Al-Manar, the Lebanese TV channel-- not on the news broadcast, but on the call-in shows. Viewers would phone in and repeat the rumors as the truth.
不清楚这个谣言有多大范围的认同。它似乎起源于哈马斯网站——没错，他们有网站。然后通过黎巴嫩电视电台Al-Manar传播——不是新闻广播，而是在电话直播节目中。观众会打电话进来把谣言当成真事来重复。
There's no polling of Arabs or Arab Americans on these kinds of things. But of the five representatives of Arab American organizations I spoke to, all of them had heard of this rumor, and all of them said it's not widely believed here in the States. Lots of rumors get more play.
没有关于阿拉伯人或阿拉伯裔美国人对这类事情的民意调查。但在我交谈过的五位阿拉伯裔美国人组织代表中，所有人都听说过这个谣言，也都表示在美国这里并不被广泛相信。很多谣言传播得更广。
For instance, there was a rumor a few months ago that McDonald's was donating its profits to Israel. A spokesman for the Arab American anti-defamation league in Washington says he got over 4,000 emails about that rumor. By comparison, he's received only 15 or 20 emails on this latest one.
例如，几个月前有个谣言说麦当劳把利润捐给以色列。华盛顿阿拉伯裔美国人反诽谤联盟的一位发言人说，他收到了超过4000封关于那个谣言的电子邮件。相比之下，他关于这最新一个谣言只收到了15到20封邮件。
One reason Rawah's family believes the rumor is true is this: who benefits from the attacks on the World Trade Center? Not the Arabs, they say, not the Muslims.
拉瓦家人相信这个谣言为真的一个原因是：谁从世贸中心袭击中获益？他们说，不是阿拉伯人，不是穆斯林。
Instead, Rawah says that up until this point, the war in the Middle East has been between the Arabs and Israelis. But the September 11th attacks, she says, will necessarily bring the US into that war, turning an Arab-Israeli war into an Arab and American war. As far as she's concerned, this is what Israel has wanted all along. This is why, she says, Israel would attack the US but frame the Arabs for the crime.
相反，拉瓦说，直到目前为止，中东战争一直是在阿拉伯人和以色列人之间。但她说，9月11日的袭击必然会将美国卷入那场战争，将一场阿拉伯-以色列战争变成一场阿拉伯与美国的战争。就她而言，这正是以色列一直想要的。她说，这就是为什么以色列会袭击美国，却把罪名嫁祸给阿拉伯人。
Till now, no Israeli name has been mentioned of one of the victims. No Jews, nobody has been reported that they were hurt.
到目前为止，没有一个以色列名字被列为遇难者之一。没有犹太人，没有人报道他们受了伤。
But you know what? Actually, after you and I talked, I went through and looked at names of people who were missing, and there are Jews missing.
但你知道吗？其实，在你我谈话后，我查阅了失踪人员名单，确实有犹太人失踪。
There aren't?
没有吧？
There are.
有的。
There are? That were killed in that building?
有吗？在那个大楼里遇难的？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, how about the employees that did not go to work that day?
好吧，那那天没去上班的雇员呢？
If it was true that there were 4,000 Israelis who worked at the World Trade Center and didn't show up for work that day, that would mean that one in 15 people who work at the World Trade Center are Israeli. Which is just not true. You know what I'm saying?
如果世贸中心有4000名以色列人那天没去上班是真的，那意味着世贸中心十五分之一的工作人员都是以色列人。这根本不是真的。你知道我的意思吗？
I see what you're saying. And I don't know who did it, exactly, and no one knows yet. Because no one in the world, yet, have any real evidence of who attacked the World Trade Center.
我明白你的意思。我不知道到底是谁干的，还没人知道。因为世界上至今还没人有任何真正的证据表明是谁袭击了世贸中心。
At this point, 130 Israelis are still officially unaccounted for. The confirmed Israeli deaths are these: two passengers on the hijacked planes, and the body of a third Israeli found at the World Trade Center, and buried.
目前，仍有130名以色列人正式下落不明。确认的以色列死亡人数如下：劫持飞机上的两名乘客，以及在世贸中心发现并埋葬的第三名以色列人的遗体。
Ali Abunimah says no one he knows believes the rumor about the 4,000 Israelis. But, he says, part of the rumor's appeal is that it takes the heat off Arabs.
阿里·阿布尼玛说，他认识的人都不相信4000名以色列人的谣言。但是，他说，这个谣言的部分吸引力在于它能减轻阿拉伯人的压力。
You know, one of the first feelings I had, and many others, is please God don't let this be someone from the Middle East. We don't want it to be, we disown, we renounce this act. This is a horrific atrocity, a crime against humanity was committed in New York.
你知道，我最初的感觉之一，也是许多人的感觉，就是祈求上帝千万别是中东人干的。我们不想是他们，我们否认、谴责这种行为。这是一场可怕的暴行，是对纽约犯下的反人类罪行。
So saying it's a Zionist conspiracy is a way to dissociate yourself from it completely. You know, if people supported it, they'd be saying, yay, you know, strike one for the Muslims. No one is saying that. They're all looking for a way out.
所以说这是犹太复国主义阴谋是一种完全摆脱罪责的方式。你知道，如果人们支持它，他们会说，太棒了，穆斯林赢了一局。没人会那么说。他们都在寻找出路。
Rawah just can't believe a Muslim could have been behind the attacks. The Koran wouldn't allow it. Besides, she says, where's the proof?
拉瓦只是无法相信穆斯林会是袭击的幕后黑手。古兰经不会允许的。此外，她说，证据在哪里？
And this actually seems to be the biggest difference between the way people from Arab countries see recent events and the way most Americans see them. It's not about the rumors, it's about Osama bin Laden.
这似乎是阿拉伯国家的人看待近期事件的方式与大多数美国人看待方式之间最大的区别。这无关谣言，而是关于奥萨马·本·拉登。
Most of the Arab Americans I spoke with are still waiting for proof linking him to the attacks, for some sort of hard evidence to be released to the public. And they're skeptical it'll ever come.
大多数我交谈过的阿拉伯裔美国人仍在等待将他与袭击联系起来的证据，等待某种向公众发布的铁证。而且他们怀疑证据是否真的会出现。
Rawah believes bin Laden is just a convenient scapegoat.
拉瓦认为本·拉登只是一个方便的替罪羊。
Now, I wouldn't be surprised if this Halloween you have kids and people dressed as Osama bin Laden. Strongly believe so.
现在，如果这个万圣节你看到孩子们和人们打扮成奥萨马·本·拉登的样子，我一点也不会感到惊讶。我坚信会这样。
I went to Dominick's the other day and I was shopping and I see all these Pumpkins and costumes. And there's the first thing that came into my mind. Because Americans now are afraid of something called Osama bin Laden. Or something that is called Mohammed or Islam or Arabs.
前几天我去Dominick's超市购物，看到所有这些南瓜和服装。那是我想到的第一件事。因为美国人现在害怕一种叫做奥萨马·本·拉登的东西。或者害怕一种叫做穆罕默德、伊斯兰或阿拉伯人的东西。
Rawah believes Israel is all-powerful, and capable of everything she sees as bad. Most Americans wouldn't agree with her about that.
拉瓦认为以色列全能，能够做到她认为的所有坏事。大多数美国人不会同意她的看法。
Meanwhile, from an Arab point of view, we're doing the same thing with Osama bin Laden. He seems all-powerful. We're ready to believe it was him, even if we haven't seen the greatest proof. Maybe everyone needs a boogeyman.
与此同时，从阿拉伯人的观点来看，我们在奥萨马·本·拉登身上做着同样的事。他似乎全能。我们准备好相信是他干的，即使我们还没看到最确凿的证据。也许每个人都需要一个“妖魔”。
Julie Snyder.
朱莉·斯奈德。
Act Two. Bombs over Baghdad.
第二幕，《巴格达上空的炸弹》。
Issam Shukri is an architect living in Toronto. But during the Persian Gulf War, he lived in Baghdad, where he grew up.
伊萨姆·舒克里（Issam Shukri）是一位住在多伦多的建筑师。但在海湾战争期间，他住在自己长大的巴格达。
His experience of the war was of course very different than most of ours in this country. He remembers clearly how he learned that his country had invaded Kuwait.
他对战争的经历当然与我们这个国家的大多数人非常不同。他清楚地记得他是如何得知国家入侵科威特的。
Me and my wife used to work in two different rooms in the same sort of building. And she always listened to Kuwaiti station, the national Kuwaiti station, because it has some more fun songs and mixture of songs, and stuff like that.
我和妻子以前在同一栋大楼的两个不同房间工作。她总是听科威特电台，国家科威特电台，因为它有一些更有趣的歌曲和音乐混合，诸如此类。
But anyway, so she was trying to find that station, but she couldn't. She said, Issam, it seems there's something wrong with the radio, I can't find that station.
不管怎样，当时她想找那个台，但找不到。她说，伊萨姆，收音机好像坏了，找不到那个台。
So I start to flip through the stations. And I put it on our Baghdad station, and, boy, I started to hear the marches and the military music.
于是我开始切换电台。我转到了巴格达电台，天哪，我开始听到进行曲和军乐。
Did that automatically mean you knew that there was trouble?
那是否自动意味着你知道出事了？
Yes. That was the government's sort of announcement, in music, to times of trouble. We sense it when we, for instance, hear emotional love songs, we think that the regime is taking a break a little bit.
是的。那是政府以音乐方式发出的动荡信号。例如，当我们听到情感抒情的爱情歌曲时，我们认为政权稍微休息了一下。
So at the time, we heard that and instantly we knew that there was a military or some kind of problem.
所以当时我们听到那个，立刻就知道是军事或某种问题发生了。
I heard about the invasion by dashing out into the street, and saying, what happened? And people, in a lower voice, well Saddam invaded Kuwait. And he's calling people to go and fight over there in the front.
我是冲到街上得知入侵的消息的，我问发生了什么？人们压低声音说，萨达姆入侵了科威特。他正在号召人们去前线战斗。
And I said, I sort of struck my head and I said, not again.
我拍着头说，又来了。
Had you served in the Iran-Iraq war?
你参加过两伊战争吗？
Yes, I served three years, actually.
是的，我实际上服役了三年。
And that war, of course, an incredibly bloody war. Estimates of the dead range up to 1.5 million. Iraq used chemical weapons in the war.
那场战争当然是一场极其血腥的战争。死亡人数估计高达150万。伊拉克在战争中使用了化学武器。
Can you talk about what it felt like to know that you were being called up again to fight in this conflict for somebody who you didn't support?
你能谈谈知道自己再次被征召去为你不支持的人打仗是什么感觉吗？
Well, I don't know. Ira, it's the most individualist, as well as a collective, miserable experience that you will ever have. Because you are facing, actually, not one enemy. You are facing two enemies-- one in your back, and one in your face. And when you turn to run away, you see the back enemy trying to shoot you. That is the government of Iraq, right.
嗯，我不知道。艾拉，这是你一生中会有的最个人化也是最集体的悲惨经历。因为你面对的实际上不是一个敌人。你面对两个敌人——一个在背后，一个在面前。当你转身逃跑时，你会看到背后的敌人在试图射杀你。那就是伊拉克政府，没错。
I couldn't picture myself putting on the same uniform and fighting for a regime, a bloody regime, again. So that was my feeling.
我无法想象自己再次穿上同样的制服，为一个残暴的政权作战。所以这就是我的感受。
And the next day I had to go to that military center and join the forces. But as I was an architect, I was actually allocated to the back of the front, and inside the city of Baghdad.
第二天我不得不去那个军事中心加入部队。但由于我是建筑师，我实际上被分配到了前线的后方，就在巴格达市内。
Oh so you were very lucky.
哦，那你很幸运。
I was, actually. But some of my classmates, they were sent out to the front. And some of them faced their deaths there, they were killed.
实际上是的。但我的一些同学被送到了前线。他们中的一些人死在那里了，他们被杀害了。
Did they have the same kinds of feelings about Saddam that you did? That they didn't like the regime?
他们对萨达姆和你有着同样的感受吗？他们不喜欢那个政权？
Ira, 100%, 100%, I will tell you.
艾拉，百分之百，我跟你保证，百分之百。
Talk about the air strikes. Could you talk about what that was like? You were in Baghdad when the US started its 38 day air campaign against Iraq.
谈谈空袭吧。你能谈谈那是什么感觉吗？当美国开始对伊拉克进行为期38天的空中战役时，你就在巴格达。
Right. Actually, Ira, at the time we were waiting because James Baker, at the time, warned Iraq that, we are going to put you back in the Middle Ages. And everybody knew about that, but nobody believed it.
是的。事实上，艾拉，当时我们一直在等待，因为詹姆斯·贝克（James Baker）当时警告伊拉克说，我们要让你们回到中世纪。每个人都知道这一点，但没人相信。
Nobody believed it?
没人相信？
Yes. Yes, we didn't believe that it's going to happen. It's over 100 countries are gathering their forces with an unprecedented show of force in the human history, against 22 million people. We couldn't believe that this could be something true. I couldn't believe that the representative of the most so-called civilized country would utter such nonsense. Forgive me for that.
是的。是的，我们不相信这会发生。有超过100个国家集合起来，在人类历史上进行着史无前例的武力展示，针对2200万人。我们无法相信这是真的。我无法相信所谓最文明国家的代表会说出这种废话。请原谅我这么说。
So where were you when the bombing campaign began?
那么轰炸行动开始时你在哪里？
Yeah, I was in my home with my wife and my three-year-old son. And I was renovating my house. I was like two years, three years married to my wife.
我在家里，和妻子以及三岁的儿子在一起。我当时正在装修房子。我结婚大概两三年。
And I was sort of dividing my family home into two little homes. One is for my sister and one is for my family. And as a show of, you know, emotional support, we all slept-- we had mattresses on the floor in my living room, which had doors open because I was renovating at the time. You know, I've brought a lot of paint to paint my living room.
我当时正把家分成两个小房子。一个是给我姐姐的，一个是给我们家的。作为情感支持的展示，我们都睡在一起——地板上有床垫。由于我当时正在装修，客厅门开着，我还买了很多油漆准备刷客厅。
So anyway, we slept, and that night, the night of the 17th of January, in my living room, and we sort of kissed each other and we fell asleep. And exactly at 2 A.M. we all woke up and the ground was shaking violently. And it was like a deep, deep, sort of echo happening, coming down from the ground. And the streetlights were on at the time, and in five minutes, all the lights were out.
总之，那天晚上，也就是1月17日夜里，我们睡在客厅里，吻了吻彼此，进入了梦乡。凌晨2点整，我们都惊醒了，地面在剧烈摇晃。那种感觉就像深深的地底深处发出了回响。当时路灯亮着，五分钟后，所有的灯都熄灭了。
And we, at that minute, we were certain that this is the war and we're back again. We're facing death all over again.
那一刻，我们确定战争开始了，我们又回来了。我们再次面对死亡。
I, personally, Ira, I'm not ashamed of this-- I started to shake. My hands couldn't hold anything. I grabbed my--
艾拉，我不以此为耻——我开始颤抖。双手无法握住任何东西。我抓住我的——
Take a second.
歇一会儿。
I grabbed my little kid. And he was crying, he didn't know what was happening. I remember my son, when he heard the B-52 over his head. I put my hand on his heart and I felt his heart bumping like crazy.
我抓住了我的小孩子。他在哭，他不知道发生了什么。我记得儿子听到头顶上方B-52轰炸机的声音时，我把手按在他心口，感觉到他的心脏像疯了一样猛跳。
And ironically, I went to the wash the next five, six times in five minutes. You know, when you have this kind of stress, I needed go to the wash room. As mundane as this is, but I need to tell the Americans about it.
讽刺的是，我五分钟内去了五六次洗手间。你知道，在这种压力下，我需要去洗手间。这虽然琐碎，但我需要告诉美国人这些事。
The fear is very, very frightening when you're expecting your death. It's much more frightening that when it happens suddenly, if you're asleep, or if you're embarking on your work, or whatever. But when you're expected minute by minute, second by second sometimes, it gets like a torture. So we were literally tortured.
当你在等待死亡时，恐惧是非常可怕的。比起突然发生——比如你正在睡觉，或者正在工作时——等待死亡那种分分秒秒的煎熬更令人恐惧。所以我们确实被折磨了。
And we started to wander with the streets. I looked around in my neighborhood. And, by the way, our neighborhood looks pretty much like any American or Canadian neighborhood. You know, row houses or individual homes, with the front yards very nicely done. You know, people that has the same qualities of life. The difference is that they live in constant fear.
我们开始在街上游荡。我看了看周围的街区。顺便说一句，我们的街区看起来和美国或加拿大的街区没什么两样。你知道，联排别墅或独栋房屋，院子打理得很好。人们拥有同样的生活质量。不同的是他们生活在持续的恐惧中。
And you were with your three-year-old boy.
你当时带着你三岁的儿子。
Right. Well actually, I was very worried about this guy, because he was very young. And you know when fear, when you start your life by experiencing fear and bombing, it would leave scars in your soul for the rest of your life. And I think he's fine now.
是的。其实，我非常担心这个小家伙，因为他太小了。你知道，当恐惧——当你生命开始时就经历恐惧和轰炸，这会在你灵魂深处留下余生无法愈合的创伤。我想他现在还好。
But he kept asking me, why are they doing this to us? What have we done?
但他一直问我，为什么他们要这样对待我们？我们做了什么？
And I couldn't find the right answer because he was very young at the time. I couldn't go into deep political analysis of what's going on. But I told him, there is a bad guy who did something wrong. And there are some judges of the world who wanted to take the law by their hand, and then they come and punish him. And then I stop for one second, and say, but they are punishing us. But we are scared, he's not scared.
我找不到正确的答案，因为当时他太小了。我无法深入分析正在发生的政治情况。但我告诉他，有个坏蛋做错了事。世界有些法官想亲手执行法律，于是他们来惩罚他。然后我停顿了一下说，但他们是在惩罚我们。可我们感到害怕，他却不害怕。
Did he ask, why are they bombing all of us if they're just trying to get this bad man?
他有没有问，如果他们只是想抓那个坏人，为什么要轰炸我们所有人？
Well, Ira, I didn't try to justify what the American forces were doing. To tell you the truth, I'm not going to polish my words. I told him that, you know, after days and days of bombing I at first told him that, well there are some judges who are going to catch this man. And, you know, he's an outlaw, they're going to put him in jail. I try to make things like a story to his age.
嗯，艾拉，我并没有试图为美国军队的行为辩护。说实话，我不会润色我的言语。在轰炸过了几天后，我起初告诉他，有些法官要抓住这个人。他是个罪犯，他们会把他关进监狱。我试图把事情编成适合他年龄的故事。
And then after that I start to feel frustrated, myself, because I see people slaughtered in front of my eyes. And Saddam comes out in the screens, laughing with his ugly face. So I started to tell him, well, those judges are sometimes more severe and sometimes they hit hard that the people themselves will suffer some injuries. But, again, that's OK. Probably in the end, they will catch him.
在那之后，我自己开始感到沮丧，因为我看着人们在我眼前被屠杀。而萨达姆出现在屏幕上，带着他丑陋的脸笑着。所以我开始告诉他，那些法官有时比较严厉，有时打击太重，导致人们自己也会受到一些伤害。但，还是那句话，没关系。可能最后他们会抓住他的。
But it never happened. And now he knows that it's not going to happen, neither in Iraq nor in Afghanistan, nor in anywhere in the world.
但这从未发生。现在他知道这不会发生，无论是在伊拉克、阿富汗，还是世界上的任何地方。
Was there a part of you which hoped the Americans would succeed and liberate Iraq from Saddam Hussein?
你内心是否有部分希望美国能成功，把伊拉克从萨达姆·侯赛因手中解放出来？
To tell you the truth, I hoped for that. But I felt deep, deep in heart that they're not going to catch this person. I've always doubted that. And not only me, all the people in Iraq doubted that. Because there is always history that tells you lessons.
说实话，我确实那样希望过。但我内心深处感到他们抓不住这个人。我一直对此表示怀疑。不仅是我，伊拉克所有人都怀疑。因为历史总是会给你教训。
And there is the fresh memory when Saddam used the chemical weapons against Halabja-- which is a northern, very, very peaceful city-- in 1988, and killed 5,000 people in two hours. Nobody in the West raised a finger. Nobody called him a terrorist, nobody called him a tyrant.
还有一个新鲜的记忆，萨达姆在1988年对哈拉布贾（Halabja）——一个非常非常和平的北方城市——使用了化学武器，两小时内杀死了5000人。西方没有一个人伸出援手。没有人叫他恐怖分子，没有人叫他暴君。
But when he touched a state that is a strong ally to the West, a state that is very rich in oil. So we didn't have really trust to the West. It's a feeling that those people do not care about other nations. They can bomb any city, any minute, any time, without warning.
但当他触碰了一个作为西方坚定盟友的国家，一个盛产石油的国家时，他们就行动了。所以我们并没有真正信任西方。这是一种感觉，那些人并不关心其他国家。他们可以在没有警告的情况下，随时随地轰炸任何城市。
And what did you think about the United States at that time? Did you hate the United States for the bombing? Did you feel a mix of feelings about it, because you hoped that they would come in?
那你当时怎么看美国？你因为轰炸而憎恨美国吗？你对此感觉复杂吗，因为你希望他们能进来？
I didn't like the United States. As a government, as a military force-- not the people. I saw cruise missiles falling on buildings that are exactly-- unfortunately, I would say that it looked exactly to me like the World Trade Center. I mean, when I saw the World Trade Center, those airplanes crashing into it, the first thing jumped into my head was when I saw one of the buildings-- I was driving from one part of the city to the other-- and I saw one of these building hit by a cruise missile. But some of these buildings where inhabited by civilians.
我不喜欢美国。作为一个政府，作为一个军事力量——不是指美国人民。我看到巡航导弹落在大楼上，看起来完全——不幸的是，我会说在我看来它们和世贸中心看起来一模一样。我的意思是，当我看到世贸中心，那些飞机撞向它时，我脑子里闪现的第一件事就是我看到其中一栋大楼——当时我正从城市的一头开车到另一头——看到这些建筑之一被巡航导弹击中。但其中一些建筑物里住着平民。
So, I do not hate, I don't like to use this word, but I was mad, I was angry at the United States government. Because it uses a lot of force, inhuman force, to punish very poor people.
所以，我并不憎恨，我不喜欢用这个词，但我很生气，我对我对美国政府感到生气。因为它使用大量的武力，非人的武力，去惩罚非常贫穷的人民。
And were you also angry in Saddam for putting you all in this position?
那你也因为萨达姆让你们所有人处于这种境地而生他的气吗？
Oh, in that respect, we hated Saddam. I would definitely use that word.
哦，在那方面，我们憎恨萨达姆。我绝对会用那个词。
Issam Shukri in Toronto. In his spare time, he does a little work with a group that's trying to lift the economic sanctions that stop food and medicines from going into Iraq.
伊萨姆·舒克里，在多伦多。在业余时间，他与一个试图解除经济制裁、让食物和药品进入伊拉克的团体合作。
He points out that 5,000 civilians are dying every month that the sanctions continue. Five thousand a month, every month, for the past 11 years.
他指出，随着制裁的持续，每个月都有5000名平民死亡。每个月5000人，在过去11年里，每个月都是如此。
Coming up, the war ahead, and lessons from a half hour battle that got out of hand in 1993. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，未知的战争，以及1993年一场失控的半小时战斗的教训。一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, current events Rashomon in which we look at familiar news stories from unfamiliar points of view, hoping that might shed some light on things, give some perspective on troubling events. We've arrived at Act Three of our program.
今天我们的节目是“当前事件版罗生门”，我们从陌生的角度审视熟悉的新闻故事，希望能照亮一些东西，对棘手事件提供一些视角。我们进入了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. Toto, I don't think we're in Vietnam, anymore.
第三幕，《托托，我想我们不在越南了》。
We've been told that the first part of the coming war on terror will involve US special operation forces tracking down suspected terrorists. Perhaps it would be helpful to remember another mission like that in this moment.
我们被告知，即将到来的反恐战争的第一阶段将涉及美国特种作战部队追捕嫌疑恐怖分子。在这一时刻，回顾一下另一次那样的任务也许会有所帮助。
In the early 1990s, there was a UN peacekeeping mission in Somalia. In that country there were a number of rival factions competing for power.
在20世纪90年代初，联合国在索马里执行维和任务。那个国家有许多竞争权力的敌对派系。
In June of 1993, a local militia leader named Mohamed Aidid ambushed and killed 19 Pakistani soldiers from the UN mission. The Clinton administration dispatched a squad of special operatives to capture Aidid and dismantle his military organization. The squad consisted of two elite military teams, the Rangers and the Delta Force. On October 3, 1993, their mission was to capture two of Aidid's top commanders.
1993年6月，一名当地民兵领导人名叫穆罕默德·法拉赫·艾迪德（Mohamed Aidid），他伏击并杀死了联合国维和部队的19名巴基斯坦士兵。克林顿政府派遣了一支特种作战部队去抓捕艾迪德并拆除他的军事组织。这支部队由两支精英军事小组组成：游骑兵（Rangers）和三角洲部队（Delta Force）。1993年10月3日，他们的任务是抓捕艾迪德的两名高级指挥官。
Mark Bowden wrote a book about the battle called Black Hawk Down . He talked to producer Alex Blumberg about that day and the mission to capture those two men.
马克·鲍登（Mark Bowden）写了一本关于那场战斗的书，名为《黑鹰坠落》（Black Hawk Down）。他与制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）谈到了那一天以及抓捕那两人的任务。
And they had been spotted speaking at a rally in Mogadishu earlier that morning, and had been observed by spies on the ground and in the air traveling to a house in the center of Mogadishu, in an area called the Bakara Market.
当天早上，他们被发现在摩加迪沙的一次集会上发表讲话，并被地面和空中的间谍监视，看到他们前往摩加迪沙市中心一个叫巴卡拉市场（Bakara Market）地区的一所房子。
And so General William F. Garrison, who was the leader of Task Force Ranger, authorized a raid which was to swoop in very quickly on this house and arrest these two guys and anyone who was with them, and bring them back to the base.
因此，游骑兵特遣队指挥官威廉·加里森（William F. Garrison）将军授权了一次突袭，旨在迅速冲进这所房子，逮捕这两个家伙以及任何与他们在一起的人，并把他们带回基地。
And the mission, it didn't exactly work out the way it was supposed to.
结果任务并没有完全按照预期进行。
No. The mission was envisioned as taking about 30 minutes-- or basically 30 minutes on the ground and maybe another 30 minutes to convoy the prisoners out of the city.
是的。任务设想大约需要30分钟——基本上是在地面30分钟，然后再花30分钟把俘虏从城里撤出来。
In the end, how long did it end up taking and how many lives were lost?
最后，实际上花了多长时间？有多少生命损失？
In the end, the battle lasted about 15 hours, through a long night and into early the next day. Eighteen American soldiers were killed. It was the most significant firefight that American soldiers have been involved with since the war in Vietnam.
最终，战斗持续了约15个小时，经过了一个漫长的夜晚，一直持续到第二天清晨。18名美国士兵阵亡。这是自越战以来美国士兵参与的最严重的交火事件。
The way the raid was set up, the Delta Force operators would hit the ground first. They ride on benches on the outside of these little helicopters-- AH-6s, they call them Little Birds-- and are literally put right down in front of the house. They land right on the street. So the Delta Force operators were inserted in that way.
按照突袭的布置，三角洲部队的操作员先降落地面。他们坐在这些小型直升机——他们称之为“小鸟”（Little Birds）——外面的长凳上，真的是被直接放到房子前面。他们直接着陆在街道上。所以三角洲部队就是这样切入的。
And then the bigger Blackhawk helicopters come in. The Blackhawks are too big to land on the street. So they hover overhead, and the Rangers rope down to each of the four corners of the block where this operation was taking place.
然后更大的黑鹰直升机进来。黑鹰太大，无法在街道上降落。所以它们在头顶盘旋，游骑兵顺着绳索降落到任务所在街区的四个角。
Well, what was the first thing that didn't go as planned?
那么，第一件没有按计划进行的事情是什么？
Well as the Rangers roped into the four corners, one of the young rangers, a fellow named Todd Blackburn, actually missed the rope and fell 70 feet from the helicopter to the street. You know, this was the most serious injury that any of these units had sustained since they'd come a month before. And it caused certainly a great deal of alarm within his little Ranger unit there.
当游骑兵顺绳索降落到四个角时，其中一名年轻的游骑兵，一个叫托德·布莱克本（Todd Blackburn）的人，实际上没抓稳绳子，从70英尺高的直升机上摔到了大街上。你知道，这是这些部队自一个月前到来以来遭受的最严重受伤。这无疑在他那个小小的游骑兵单位内引起了极大的恐慌。
And it set in motion a chain of events that kind of just slowed the whole process down. Not a lot, but a little.
它引发了一系列事件，减缓了整个进程。虽然不多，但确实造成了延误。
One of the very first things in the book is when you're talking about, they're hanging from these helicopters on these ropes, they're seventy feet above the ground, they have to slide down these ropes, and then sort of establish their position. And just the confusion of it all was just-- like, what do they see as they're coming down?
书中的第一个场景就是当他们悬挂在这些直升机上、离地70英尺时，他们必须滑下绳索，然后建立位置。那种混乱简直——他们降落时看到了什么？
Well, initially, as the men descended the ropes to the street, they could see almost nothing. Because the helicopters, the Blackhawks are so powerful, they kicked up huge clouds of dust. So they're roping down in a dust storm, so they can't really even see much past their nose. And they're hearing, for the first time, pretty heavy fire. Learning the sound of bullets that pass very closely make a loud, cracking noise, like a piece of hickory being snapped.
最初，当士兵们顺绳降到街道时，几乎什么都看不见。因为直升机，黑鹰的功率太大了，卷起了巨大的尘土云。所以他们是在沙尘暴中降落，根本看不清前面的情况。他们第一次听到了非常密集的枪声。学会了子弹近距离经过时会产生巨大的破裂声，就像山核桃木折断的声音。
So the only way you can tell how close a bullet is is by the sound it makes?
所以判断子弹距离有多近的唯一方法是听它发出的声音？
That's what they tell me. I've never, fortunately, been in a situation where people have been shooting at me. But there's sort of a whooshing sound that you hear if the bullet passes somewhere in your vicinity. But if it's close enough to you, you hear what's essentially a little sonic boom as the round goes past you. And, of course, they say the one that hits you, you never hear.
他们是这么告诉我的。幸运的是，我从未处于人们向我射击的境地。但如果子弹在你附近经过，你会听到一种呼啸声。但如果它离你足够近，你会听到一声小小的音爆，就像子弹从你身边飞过一样。当然，他们说，打中你的那颗子弹，你永远听不到。
And most of the guys were learning this for the first time on this mission.
大多数士兵也是第一次在这次任务中了解到这一点。
That's right. These are very young soldiers, they're well-trained, and very cocky, and very capable. But they had never been exposed to fire like this. And they had never seen the guys next to them suddenly start to drop.
没错。这些是非常年轻的士兵，训练有素，傲慢且有能力。但他们从未经历过这样的火力。他们也从未见过身边的人突然倒下。
Matt Eversmann, who was put in charge of this mission for the first time, one by one the men in his unit scattered around the street where they'd just landed are beginning to sustain injuries.
第一次负责这次任务的马特·埃弗斯曼（Matt Eversmann），他所在单位的人一个接一个地分散在刚降落的街道上，开始出现伤亡。
They get shot.
他们中弹了。
They get shot, right. One of them gets his thumb shot off, another gets shot in the shoulder-- he just starts seeing his men go down. So this was a very, very dangerous place to go.
没错，他们中弹了。一个人大拇指被射掉，另一个肩膀中弹——他开始看到自己的手下倒下。所以这是一个非常、非常危险的地方。
The rules of engagement were that the men, the American soldiers, were not allowed to shoot at someone unless they were pointing their weapons at them. And so the Somalis knew the rules of engagement. So they mingled in with the angry crowds, who were not armed, so that they could fire at the Rangers without the Rangers being able to shoot back at them.
交战规则是，美国士兵在对方没有把武器指向他们之前不准射击。所以索马里人知道这个规则。他们混入愤怒的、没武装的人群中，这样他们就能向游骑兵开火，而游骑兵无法向他们还击。
There was literally a scene where one of the Rangers was confronted with a Somali gunman who was laying on the ground. And he had children sitting on top of him. And I think he had a woman standing right in front of him. He had basically surrounded himself with non-competents so that he could lay there and shoot at the Rangers without being shot at himself. And actually what the Rangers in the situation did, was lay down a line of fire right in front of this man-- the children and the women fled very quickly, and then they shot the gunman.
确实有一个场景：一名游骑兵面对一个躺在地上的索马里枪手。他身上坐着孩子。我觉得他前面还站着个女人。他基本上把自己周围布满了非战斗人员，这样他就可以躺在那儿向游骑兵开火而不受还击。实际上，现场的游骑兵所做的是，在那个人面前扫射出一道火线——孩子们和妇女很快逃跑了，然后他们击毙了枪手。
But eventually, they were under so much fire that the rules of engagement were just dropped. Because they realized that they had to shoot back. If they didn't, they weren't going to survive. So some of these young men were in the position of having to shoot at crowds of people in order to avoid being killed, themselves.
但最终，他们承受了太大的火力，交战规则不得不放弃。因为他们意识到必须还击。如果不那样做，他们就无法存活。所以其中一些年轻人不得不为了保命而向人群射击。
So then, what happened after that?
那么，之后发生了什么？
Well they proceeded to evacuate Todd Blackburn. The Rangers fanned out and formed the perimeter like they were supposed to. They began coming under more and more fire as the minutes went by. The Delta Operators arrested the people they were looking for. They found them and handcuffed them and were leading them out of the building, when one of the Blackhawk helicopters that was still circling overhead, was hit by a rocket-propelled grenade, and crashed about four blocks away.
他们随后撤离了托德·布莱克本。游骑兵像预想的那样散开并建立了防御圈。随着时间的推移，他们遭受的火力越来越猛。三角洲部队抓获了他们寻找的人。他们找到了人并给他们戴上手铐，正把他们从大楼里带出来时，其中一架仍在头顶盘旋的黑鹰直升机被火箭助推榴弹击中，坠毁在四个街区外。
[RADIO]
[电台声音]
All of the men involved in this mission are communicating with themselves by radio. All of these conversations were tape recorded. One of the things that I found remarkable about listening to the audio tape is that you can hear the intensity of that moment. When that Blackhawk helicopter crashes, you hear men shouting into the radio, we've got a Blackhawk down. And you can hear the panic, almost, in their voices.
所有参与此次任务的人员都通过无线电进行通讯。所有这些对话都有录音。在听这些录音时，我发现一件引人注目的事，你能听到那一刻的紧张感。当那架黑鹰直升机坠毁时，你会听到人们在无线电里喊叫，“我们有一架黑鹰坠落”。你可以听到他们声音里的恐慌。
[RADIO COMMUNICATION BETWEEN BLACKHAWK AND BASE]
[黑鹰与基地之间的电台通话]
To them, if you're on the ground in a city with literally thousands, if not tens of thousands of people surrounding you and shooting at you, your faith in getting out of there alive rests largely on those helicopters overhead. They are symbols for you of the fact that you're there representing the most powerful military force in the world.
对他们来说，如果你身处一个有成千上万甚至上万人包围并向你射击的城市，活着出来的信心很大程度上取决于头顶上的那些直升机。它们是你代表世界上最强大军事力量的象征。
When the Blackhawk was shot down, that was the defining moment of this episode. The idea was to insert the men, take the prisoners, load them on vehicles, and drive them out of the city, and everyone would come back and have a barbecue. But once that Blackhawk went down, everything changed. Because now they had men down on the ground, either dead, wounded or fighting for their lives, and they had to try to rescue those men who had just crashed.
当黑鹰被击落时，那是这次事件的决定性时刻。原来的计划是切入、抓捕俘虏、装车、开车撤出城市，然后大家回来开烧烤派对。但一旦黑鹰坠落，一切都变了。因为现在他们有士兵在地面，要么死亡，要么受伤，要么在为生命而战，他们必须去营救那些刚刚坠毁的士兵。
[RADIO COMMUNICATION BETWEEN BLACKHAWK AND BASE]
[黑鹰与基地之间的电台通话]
And so basically the convoy, which originally had been planned to just go back to the base with the prisoners, now has a totally different sort of mission.
所以基本上，原本计划只是把俘虏带回基地的车队，现在肩负着完全不同的任务。
Right. Well this became one of the major phases of the battle, and certainly the bloodiest phase. Once the Blackhawk was shot down, the orders were for the convoy to load up the prisoners and then drive to the neighborhood where the Blackhawk had crashed. And the idea was then to rescue the men who had been aboard the helicopter and then drive out of the city.
没错。这成了战斗的主要阶段之一，当然也是最血腥的阶段。黑鹰被击落后，命令是让车队装上俘虏，然后开往黑鹰坠毁的街区。目标是营救直升机上的士兵，然后开车冲出城市。
But the problem was that the streets of Mogadishu are like a maze. And at this point, there are Somalis setting up burning barricades, and organizing ambushes at intersections. So as the convoy began to try to make its way to the downed Blackhawk, it got lost.
但问题是摩加迪沙的街道就像迷宫。此时，索马里人正在设置燃烧的路障，并在十字路口组织伏击。当车队试图前往坠毁的黑鹰时，他们迷路了。
[RADIO]
[电台]
It became a tragic comedy of errors with the pilots in the helicopters overhead. And there was a Navy plane, a P-3 Orion, flying high overhead, all of them trying to give directions to this convoy. But because of the, in some cases, the relay system of communicating to them, the people in the vehicles would get the instructions too late to take advantage of them.
这成了一出悲喜剧，头顶上的直升机飞行员，还有一架高空飞行、在那儿盘旋的P-3猎户座海军飞机，都在试图指挥车队。但由于某些情况下通讯的中继系统问题，车队人员往往太晚收到指示，无法利用。
So for instance, someone high overhead would say take a left. And by the time that communicated to Danny McKnight in the lead vehicle, they'd already passed the point where they were supposed to take a left.
例如，高空有人说向左转。等到信息传给排头车辆的丹尼·麦克奈特（Danny McKnight）时，他们已经错过了该左转的路口。
[RADIO COMMUNICATION BETWEEN BLACKHAWK AND BASE]
[黑鹰与基地之间的电台通话]
The men in the vehicles in the rear of the convoy didn't even know what was going on. A lot of them still thought they were driving out of the city because no one had communicated to everybody down the line exactly where it was they were going and what they were trying to do. So you have these men holed up in these vehicles, one by one getting injured or killed, and not knowing where they were going, why they were making the turns they were making.
车队后部的士兵甚至不知道发生了什么。许多人仍然以为他们正在撤出城市，因为没有人向所有人传达清楚他们要去哪里，试图做什么。所以这些士兵被困在车辆里，一个接一个地受伤或阵亡，却不知道自己在哪里，为什么会进行那些转弯。
And it's not something where you can stay inside. Like, a Humvee isn't actually that much protection, it turns out.
而且这不像是在室内。事实证明，悍马车并没有那么好的保护力。
Right. The convoy was made up of two five ton trucks, flatbed trucks, with the prisoners in the back, and, I believe, six Humvees. And they discovered that rounds could go right through the skin of the Humvee.
没错。车队由两辆五吨重的平板卡车（后面装着俘虏）和大约六辆悍马车组成。他们发现子弹可以直接穿透悍马的皮。
For instance, one of the Humvees took a direct hit from a rocket-propelled grenade, which penetrated through the side and exploded in the back, blowing the men who were in the back of the Humvee out the rear of the vehicle, out onto the street. A couple of those men were killed, two or three others were severely injured.
例如，其中一辆悍马被一枚火箭助推榴弹直接击中，穿透侧面并在后部爆炸，把悍马后部的士兵炸到了车外，炸到了街上。其中几人当场阵亡，两三名士兵受重伤。
Whenever anything like that would happen, the convoy would stop, the men would all have to pile out. They would try to rescue the men who were injured, get them back on the vehicles, start up again. Every time they would stop, they would come under heavy fire. Until finally, more than half of the men on that convoy were either dead or injured.
每当这种事发生，车队就必须停下，所有人必须跳下车。他们试图营救受伤的士兵，把他们抬上车，重新出发。每次停下，他们就会遭到猛烈火力攻击。直到最后，车队里超过一半的人员伤亡。
And it's especially heartbreaking when you read, because several times the convoy swings a block away from where the trapped people are.
当你读到这里时，特别令人心碎，因为车队有好几次就在被困人员隔壁的街区擦身而过。
Yeah. And it just shows you how chaotic the situation was on the street. There was this feeling expressed by one of the Air Force combat controllers who was in one of the lead vehicles, his name is Dan Schilling-- he couldn't understand what was going on, and he just believed they were going to keep driving around until they were all dead.
是的。这显示了街头局势是多么混乱。其中一辆排头车上的空军战斗管制员丹·席林（Dan Schilling）表达了一种感受——他无法理解发生了什么，只是认为他们会一直开车兜圈子，直到所有人阵亡。
You know, at this point in the book, you're sort of midway through the book, one of the things that becomes very clear is that it's almost as if the entire city now has-- I don't want to say turned against, because I feel like maybe that's not the right word--
你知道，读到书的这一半时，有件事变得非常清晰，就好像整个城市现在已经——我不想说“转向敌对”，因为我觉得那可能不是正确的词——
No, it's exactly the right word.
不，这正是正确的词。
Is it?
是吗？
I mean, the Rangers said that they felt like it was kill an American day in Mogadishu. There was so much anger and hostility toward these American troops, that it virtually was true. That they were trapped in a city where everyone in the city, it seemed, was trying to kill them. And this is not just a normal city, this is the most heavily-armed population, probably in the world. And so they were under intensive fire from 360 degrees.
我的意思是，游骑兵说他们感觉那天在摩加迪沙就是“杀美国人日”。对这些美军士兵有如此多的愤怒和敌意，这几乎是真的。他们被困在一个城市里，似乎每个人都在试图杀死他们。这不仅仅是一个普通的城市，这可能是世界上武装程度最高的平民群体。所以他们遭受了来自360度方向的密集火力。
Do you think they had a sense of the enormous hostility that was pent up out there?
你认为他们当时意识到了外面积压的巨大敌意吗？
I think that they probably were aware that there was hostility against them, but they couldn't have imagined the intensity of it.
我想他们可能意识到有敌意，但无法想象其强度。
You have to remember, these are the best-trained soldiers in the world. They have the best equipment, they have these helicopters, which are absolute marvels of military technology, to support them. So they had, I think, a really cocky attitude. The idea that they would find themselves so outnumbered, and outgunned, and at a disadvantage, in a place like Mogadishu where they viewed the people they were fighting against as just a ragtag bunch of irregulars who wouldn't know how to put together an assault if their life depended on it-- now, though, they found themselves in, really, a predicament from which a lot of them had no reason to expect that they were going to get out alive.
你得记住，这是世界上训练最精良的士兵。他们有最好的装备，有这些作为军事技术奇迹的直升机支援。所以我想他们确实有一种傲慢的态度。他们认为自己会被如此悬殊的兵力包围、被火力压制，并陷入如此困境，在一个摩加迪沙这样的地方，把对手看作是一群连组织袭击都不会的乌合之众——然而，现在他们发现自己陷入了一个许多人没想到能活着出来的绝境。
You know, clearly, from what everybody's been saying about the current situation in Afghanistan, is that the military part of the response is probably going to involve-- almost certain to involve-- special operations forces, some of which may be already on the ground in Afghanistan. Pretty much exactly what you're describing.
显然，从大家对阿富汗局势的说法来看，反应的军事部分很可能涉及到——几乎肯定会涉及到——特种作战部队，其中一些可能已经进入阿富汗。这和你描述的几乎一模一样。
Well, in fact involving the same units and in some cases the same men.
嗯，事实上确实涉及同样的部队，在某些情况下还是同一些人。
What thoughts do you have about that?
你对此有什么想法？
You know, what I hope the book Blackhawk Down does is sober people up to the reality of combat. And I'm not arguing, and I don't think the book argues, makes a pacifist argument, that we shouldn't be using military force. I think we're clearly in a position right now where will the moral obligation is to use military force.
你知道，我希望《黑鹰坠落》这本书能让人们清醒地认识到战争的现实。我不是在争辩，我认为书里也没有争辩，不是在做和平主义的论证，说我们不该使用军事力量。我认为我们现在的处境显然是道德上有义务使用军事力量。
The problem with the Battle of Mogadishu was, that none of the civilian leadership in the United States, from the President to the Congress, had imagined that these raids could turn out with so many people killed and injured. So their response, when this happened, was one of horror, that this was a disaster.
摩加迪沙之战的问题在于，美国从总统到国会的平民领导层中，没有人预料到这些突袭会导致这么多人伤亡。所以当这发生时，他们的反应是惊恐，认为这是一场灾难。
And so immediately, President Clinton called off the military mission in Mogadishu. But from a military perspective, the military objective was to capture Hasan Awale and Omar Salad. They were both captured and evacuated from the city and were in custody at the end of the day. And I think it was galling to the military, particularly to the men who took part in this, to have this mission viewed as a debacle. Because they felt that they've been successful, and they felt that after so much sacrifice, their strong desire was to stay and finish the mission, if only to honor the memory of the men who had been killed accomplishing it.
于是克林顿总统立即取消了在摩加迪沙的军事任务。但从军事角度来看，军事目标是抓捕哈桑·阿瓦莱（Hasan Awale）和奥马尔·萨拉德（Omar Salad）。他们两人最终都被抓获并撤离了城市，在当天结束时已被关押。我认为这对军方，特别是对参与其中的士兵来说，将这次任务视为溃败是令人愤慨的。因为他们觉得自己成功了，在付出这么多牺牲后，他们强烈的愿望是留下来完成任务，哪怕只是为了纪念那些为达成目标而阵亡的战友。
Mark, did the Pentagon, did they study this battle? Did they sort of look at it a year or two later and just sort of say OK, what happened here, what went on, what are the things we can learn from this?
马克，五角大楼是否研究了这场战斗？他们在一两年后是否回顾了一下，然后说：好的，发生了什么？我们能从中学到什么？
Well, much to my amazement, I don't think that the Army seriously studied this episode at all, this battle at all. It just boggles my mind, when you consider that this is probably the only instance of serious, real world fighting that American soldiers have had to do, certainly since the Persian Gulf War. And there was nothing like this even in the Persian Gulf War.
嗯，令我吃惊的是，我不认为陆军认真研究过这件事，没有研究过这场战斗。当你考虑到这可能是自海湾战争以来，美国士兵唯一不得不参与的严肃、真实的实战，这简直让我无法理解。即使在海湾战争中也没有像这样的情况。
And you would think, just from a standpoint of evaluating the effectiveness of weaponry, of armor, and tactics, that they would want to examine very carefully what happened here. You know, I found myself in the position when I began working on this book, of being the first person who had attempted to really examine exactly what happened in detail.
你会认为，仅仅从评估武器、装甲和战术有效性的角度来看，他们也会想仔细评估这里发生的事情。你知道，当我开始写这本书时，我发现自己是第一个试图详细考究到底发生了什么的人。
Mark Bowden. His account of the Battle of Mogadishu is called Blackhawk Down . Of 160 Americans in the fight, 73 were injured, 18 died. A conservative estimate of the number of Somalis dead-- 500 to 1,000.
马克·鲍登。他关于摩加迪沙之战的记述名为《黑鹰坠落》。在战斗的160名美国人中，73人受伤，18人阵亡。索马里人阵亡人数的保守估计是500到1000人。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support for this program comes from PBS, presenting Life 360, a new series that explores life's surprises. Friday nights at 9:00, local times may vary.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。本节目由PBS赞助，PBS带来了探索生命惊喜的新系列节目《生活360》。周五晚9点播出，当地时间可能有所不同。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wishes our format included more of--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他希望我们的节目形式能包含更多——
The marches, and the military music.
进行曲和军乐。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。